so these guys are called binturongs This
is a binteron okay these are we're gonna
oh it's eating food no no it says in the
Bible bintron should not eat uh monkey
food so these guys they're just going
yeah I'm gonna give you this bowl all
right food okay and then you're gonna
have that before buddy these guys are
babies these are baby benches baby
binturons how big do they get no no no
species of food
they get to be about twice the size look
it's eating here the flowers it doesn't
want to eat what you brought come here
oh hi binturon yeah if you put the food
yeah there we go there we go and give it
all the food or just one at a time let's
you know if you hold the bowl let's even
get her to stand up okay you can kind of
see how big they are wow yeah so these
guys live in Southeast Asia they live in
the rainforest there as well they kind
of smell like popcorn they do what does
that smell it really does they smell
like movie theater popcorn I'm not
kidding it's just their natural odor you
know some animals have a natural scent
that's stinky some of them don't and
these why would you if you're trying to
evade Predators walk through life
smelling like movie theater popcorn well
because you know I would think nothing
would lead to Extinction why buddy but
he just looked at me like oh
you know and that's a good question you
know all animals have an odor and yeah
but leopard in in the jungle is not
going to recognize popcorn as a here
I'll take that one it's weird because it
would just be like I I it's like
smelling like uh Ranch Cool Ranch
Doritos you know it just seems like it's
a weird uh right here no right here
right here
so you'll get another animal that's
declining because of habitat loss and
again that's why the National Wildlife
Federation needs everybody to join our
mission to help us oh she's found the
monkey food in the bag down here
um put a convenient placement for you
I'll just keep this monkey food and
crotch if that's okay to do because I oh
look what happened well what can be done
she doesn't have an st a monthly food
all right
um animal looking around all right I
think we have to move quickly because we
have a lot of animals to get through uh
next animal is it's actually pretty
amazing hey buddy I'm gonna hand this to
you Cody right here oh my God okay and I
want you to step over to the side here
all right I have to do it I do have to
say to the crowd uh this giraffe gets
very scared of noise so let's try and be
very quiet yes like you were at the
start of the monologue so kind of if you
stand right here you can offer her this
bottle
this is obviously a giraffe his name's
tiny yeah he's only a couple months old
obviously he's a huge animal he's about
eight feet tall you want to hold it hold
it up so yeah there we go good oh God
and the reason we have to be quiet is
that even though he's a baby and even
though he's an herbivore he's
tremendously powerful giraffes adult
giraffes can actually kill a lion by
kicking them so even a baby giraffe at
this size if he were to Spook and kick
out he could actually injure someone so
that's why we needed everybody to be be
quiet but still amazing amazing I
mention any of this at rehearsal you
didn't say that this is an animal that
could kill me as I'm feeding a comically
large I didn't want to Spook you but
okay but you know giraffes actually have
the same number of neck bones as people
do even though their necks are long the
bones are just really big and when he
gets to be a little bit older giraffes
are herbivores as I mentioned they eat
tree leaves and they do it by sticking
their tongues out and their tongues
actually are kind of like a gray blue
color so they don't get sunburned looks
pretty amazing the eye is the eyes are
just so big and those eyes um those
paintings in motels those cute you know
what I mean those like adorable those
huge eyes actually help the giraffe spot
predators and there are need some
animals like lions that can kill these
guys okay we're almost out of milk what
happens I have another bottle here oh
thank God his fangs come out that and
then he comes after okay so he would he
would if if he were spooked right now
what he would do is he'd start kicking
me he would he would sort of kick out
and kind of pull on the leash I'm
actually hiding the other bottle because
if he sees the other bottle on the other
side he might actually try to get up
you've also positioned yourself behind
me exactly I I I'm smart I know what I'm
doing
smart all right yeah so those big eyes
help them spot Predators other animals
watch giraffes to see if there are
predators coming so they're kind of like
the early warning system milk out and
one more all right and then we'll do
this one uh I'm gonna have to go to
commercial uh these are a fascinating
animals thank you so much for bringing
them by this guy is absolutely gorgeous
how old he's only about two months old
months old born two months ago yep
unbelievable David Miss ajewski thank
you so much we'll be right back Hannah
Simone from New Girl Let's just snap our
approval for this segment
groovy baby groovy baby we'll be right
back after this